So in summary I am on top of things and
(crash)
(scream)
(baby crying)
Ok, I'm out
(scream)
And let that teach you a valuable lesson
What lesson?!
(baby crying)
I will get back to you when I figure that out
Come on
It's headed for the break room!
Stuart, get sugared up!
(screaming)
So, he gets cookies??
Looks like you're not done here after all, Templeton.
I'll take Stacy and deal with the Jimbo situation
That one's on you
Ummm
Is there like a security guard, or...?
Triplets!
Yes, boss?
Reporting for duty!
Hi, boss' brother!
Call me when you've got him contained. Don't get me fired!
I'm a security! (ambulance sounds)
Goo-goo, ga-ga?
So, is the giant muscle baby working with the killer robot swing, or?
Who cares! Get in there and find my little boy!
What did you do?
Whaaaaa?
Scooter!
Hey, everything's under control here
You're an atrocious liar, but that's not what I'm calling about. The Busky house is surrounded!
We had to send out the baby swing as a distraction
It's got my gun!
I need you to scan the big board and find us an escape route
Tick tock, Templeton, this situation is at crisis levels here!
Stacy, how's the neighborhood?
People are really hating baby, sir!
Okay, I have an idea!
And I have a crisis. Winner? Me.
Where's my escape route?
Oh, Scooter!
I found more cookies and juice boxes!
Templeton!
Templeton where are you? I've lost contact.
Block the door
Nooo!
They can't send me back to day care
Oh, thank goodness.
Exit route, Templeton, ASAP
Or, since I got Scooter, I could just send him back to his parents
Oh, what!
The situation is a powder keg and that baby is the blowtorch!
You send him out now and no one in this neighborhood will ever love babies again!
I absolutely forbid! wait. Where are you right now?
Too late!
Templeton, you've doomed us all
Scooter?
Baby boy!
(laughter)
We are back to work, Templeton
Hello, you beautiful baby corp!
Yes, boss?
Reporting for duty!
Hi, boss' brother!
Are they always this friendly?
I can't have my own brother ignorant to the art of business. It's embarrassing
I make sure the world loves babies more than puppies, more than kittens
What's the threat
A cat!
What?!
Cats don't play by rules
What's up?
This meeting is making me uncomfortable
What do we do?
I'm gonna bag the tiger
Are you and your brother having fun?
Nothing suspicious, I love you, bye!
This is my job on the line
You made a choice to join a family. We can fix this!
What if you broke stuff and blamed it on the cat?
Yes! Gold star for Stacey!
In fairness, sir, the cat thought of it first
You can't kill what you can't see
Time to go invisible!
Mommy is a dirty liar!